Nathan's gone back into basketball
coaching okay NBA maybe I'd be good
Haley's got an incredible music career
Jamie's probably you know I think he's
put it on his way to the NBA and then
maybe there's like a few more like 14
more kids more kids coming through the
pipeline 14 yeah yeah one hot that's
James Lafferty's dream One Tree Hill
spin-off storyline which he says he'd be
up for what about a spinoff
and Jamie's all grown up oh maybe he's
dating Lucas's daughter a man you never
know trio but I'm proud that each of you
become the kind of man I could never be
would you do that like would you play
the father figure do you think that
Nathan would be anything like Dan Scott
that would be interesting see now that
would be fun that would be that would be
a fun thing to play I go where the hell
I want to leave my family alone
I'd say Marsh mom picks up the phone and
calls and says you know I want to do
something and I always give the name for
sure
but before that happens James stars and
waffle Street out March 15th scream
veteran Danny Glover co-stars Jim only
my parents call me Jimmy will consider
me you won't daddy coming from doing
television for so long you got to stay
on booking the words are very very
important but you know with Danny who
goes from film to film it was kind of
nice to watch him riff and be like oh
yeah I could I could get into that okay
we're gonna let you go Jim it is sort of
like this redemptive story about Jimmy
Adams he's disillusioned with his life
as a as a Wall Street financier so it
says to go back to basics and and get a
job working at a 24-hour diner
you